the broadcast is now starting all
attendees are in listen only mode
good morning everybody welcome to uh st
patrick's day it's march 17th wednesday
and you know we just had that time
change
in the us over the weekend and you know
i i realize it's
uh for some people especially in some
countries i know in asia they don't
change the clock so
you know i'll just give people just 10
or 15 more seconds to come in
and get started but you know what i'll
be talking about today
is effective order flow trading
strategies and i'll be honest you know
when
when biden won the election i thought
the markets would sort of calm down a
bit you know i mean with trump
is that was always a knock on trump that
you know everything is so chaotic but
you know these markets are are have not
disappointed from a trader's standpoint
you know there's a lot of opportunities
every day
so what i'll be talking about today
everybody is you know strategies that
you can take away
and use in your trading and you know i
think the best way to
trade is by using the order flow because
basically order flow gets you as close
to
the market as possible right you want to
be no you want to know
how the market is reacting to what's
happening in the market the current
activity or the current buying the
current selling and that's important
right because you don't want to be
reacting to something that happened
earlier
or you know some sort of mathematical
equation that could
uh weight things that happened before a
little bit heavier than what's happening
now you want to be based
you're trading on what's happening right
now in the market right that's going to
give you
the best the best basically the best
advantage over other traders right that
are using
um you know indicators that may be
lagging the market
or analyzing things that happened in the
past it really has no
weight on the future okay and
order flow i'm going to show you allows
you to gauge the tendency
the market will continue in its
direction right any time a market is
trending right you you always want to
get on that trend
but eventually that trend is going to
stop you want to be looking for the
signs
you know saying you know the you know
imagine you're on the airplane you're
asleep then all of a sudden
you know the you hear on the speaker uh
good morning everybody we're
making our final approach to you know
o'hare airport
uh please fasten your seat belts and the
same thing with the market right market
gives you clues that you know what the
market's about to land
you know either stop its move up or
you know end its move down and the new
trading activity that comes into the
market which is
the volume depending on how that is
trading in the market is going to tell
you if we're going to continue in that
direction
or if the market's going to be coming in
and making its landing so to speak
okay and lastly you know the the thing
that is
really useful about order flow is it
gives you more information
than basically everybody out there right
you're not competing against the market
you're competing against other traders
right so if you can see things in the in
for in the data
right in the trading that's happening
that they're not paying attention to
or they just don't understand how to
how to use that information you're going
to have an edge over them because
at the end of the day it's not you
against the market it's you against the
other traders
how you can take the money out of their
pocket and ideally put it into your
pocket
and so today in this training you're
going to discover an easy way
to use order flow in your trading
i'll explain what makes order flow so
different and so much more effective
than
traditional market analysis you know
there's a big difference between reading
the order flow
and reading a traditional bar chart
right a traditional bar chart is just
based on open high low close
right but really what you want to do is
you you want to be looking
inside each bars and see you know why
did the market open here why did it
trade up here why did it trade down
there
and then finally closed and we'll show
you strategies that traders are using
right now in the markets so again why
order flow is because it's based on
what's happening
right now in the market right you trade
based on the present
not the past he's going to give you
better
vision of what's going on right imagine
you're in a sports analogy
you know you're playing football soccer
right you're watching how the
other team is lining up you know how
they're reacting
in the same way with trading right when
you're trading
you're watching how the market develops
right changes that are happening in the
market
and how you could use those to your
advantage because at the end of the day
you have to trade what's happening
right now now my gift to you
is a free copy of my book trading order
flow now you're not going to get a hard
cover copy like this you'll you'll get
the information on how to download it
and you can put on your phone your
computer print it up um
you know it's 150 page book that i wrote
after i left jpmorgan
and you know this was sort of originally
supposed to be my contribution to the
trading world
i'm going to show you how to get it for
free okay so
for those of you that are new to one of
my presentations
who i am my name is michael baltos i've
got over 25 years professional trading
experience i started on the cme trading
floor
okay and then i left the trading floor
when
electronic trading started happening
right this was back in the early 90s and
globex at the time was
really starting to um pick up okay but
nowhere near what it is today you know
it was you know s ps at that time the
big s ps
were still trading you know it would
trade you know it was a very busy day
in the night session it traded maybe
four thousand five thousand contracts
right and you know currencies you know
if you traded a thousand
um deutsche marks didn't have the euro
to start it up later
but at that time you know it was like it
was still a deutsche mark swiss francs
you know those contracts would trade
six seven hundred contracts a night so
i started you know when it was very
quiet and i saw the evolution but i i
realized that was
the shift in the markets right
everything was going to go electronic
and so i wanted to be
position myself for the future so after
spending about three years at dean
witter
i joined edf man in chicago the big
english trading company right it's been
around since the 1700s
and you know they trade all sorts of
commodities to trade you know it's like
the equivalent of what cargill is in the
u.s right i also worked for cargill for
about four years
i was even transferred out to singapore
to set up a trading desk for
cargill after man i joined commerce bank
in chicago
as their ux trader right i was trading
buns bobbles shots
dax euro stock stocks right and i would
trade that against the us
products so eurex at the time was was
really the first big
european exchange that was all
electronic
okay this was back in the late 90s and
you know i even then right i noticed the
shifts
in what was happening in the markets
everything
once in exchange said we're going
electronic it happened
probably lots of times it just happened
within months okay
and that's why after commerce bank after
9 11
i took about six months off traveled
around the world
you know sort of come back to reality
and then i joined cargill in chicago
on their futures trading desk and when
the exchange in singapore said we're
shutting down our trading floor
that's when cargill sent me out to
singapore to set up a off-the-floor
trading desk okay then i spent about a
year year and a half
in singapore with cargill and then after
cargill i joined jp morgan i said jp
morgan for
eight years in singapore as vice
president of futures trading
you know we're on the desk trading not
you know a vice president where you're
just sitting in an office looking at
numbers or spreadsheets
you know writing emails you know on the
desk banging away day in day out for
eight years and finally i said you know
what i have it
i i can't take it anymore
i had gotten married i had my first
child
so there's i know how to trade i just i
just walk away i was in my early 40s i
said you know what i've had enough
i'm gonna trade for myself i could write
my book
you know and just live life okay and
that's how order flows
the order flow company started right is
after leaving jp morgan i wanted to do
something
different right a different direction
honestly i didn't expect myself to get
into software okay but
the software that i was using at the
time you know it was just wasn't good
enough or complete enough i don't say
good enough you know it was it was basic
basically i mean this is in 2013 2014
and the software out there for reading
order flow would give you
delta point of control and imbalances
which i'll talk about in a minute
but i realize i have my way of analyzing
the market
using delta point of control and
imbalances so
let the computer show me that you know
sort of take off some of that heavy
lifting
from my shoulders you know doing the
analysis calculating it by hand or
you know in in my head on a calculator
said you know take that analysis put it
in a computer
and that's why i created the order flows
trader now i originally i created just
for my own use
but in my conversations with other
traders they said hey mike
how can i buy that i'm like you know
this is something we just developed for
myself
and once we saw the
you know my programmer says hey you know
i'm getting a lot of people interested
in this you know because i'd be
sending emails to other traders we'd be
talking amongst each other
other order flow traders saying hey you
know what this looks good
i could use this in my trading that's
how order flows
trader came about right the commercial
aspect of it
you know it started as my own personal
um software that i was uh that i was
using
and it sort of blossomed into you know
once everyone saw it and i said hey you
know what this can help my trading
i want to use it you know sell it to me
basically and
the charts and tools that i use in this
training are generated from my overflow
software that's why i sort of give you
that background on
the software is because what i'm showing
you
while using my software can make it very
easy
you can also apply what you're learning
you know if you're using another
company's software right
problem is people get into order flow
and
they're taught about delta point of
control and imbalance but they're not
really taught how to use them in their
analysis they talk you know what they
are
yeah which is good you should know what
they are but you have to know how
to use it okay and
you know give you an example right you
all go out and
you know now everybody's got you know
the latest iphone or you know at least
an iphone
8 or something um but my wife's got the
the 12 i'm still on the eight plus
but there's so many features right i
don't even know how to use them all
all right and you know but it the same
thing is
is like that when you're in order flow
right there's a lot of data points but
if you don't know how to use it
it's kind of useless right it's just
like buying a camera right
those big fancy canon dslr cameras that
have all these you know f
f-stops everything that that you want to
use as a photographer
but if you don't know how to use it you
just put it in automatic mode and
you know and you just spent twelve
hundred dollars on a camera that you're
really not getting the most out of and
it's the same way with order flow
if you don't know how to take that
information that you're looking at
it's really not going to be very useful
to you okay so that's my goal today is
to show you how you can
easily see things in the order flow and
apply it to your trading
now just before we sort of dive in a
brief disclaimer
you know understand that trading is
risky right you should only
risk capital is money that could be lost
without jeopardizing your financial
security or lifestyle
right basically don't trade with your
rent money your mortgage money
your kids food money basically um
you know and realize you know it's not a
race against time you know a lot of
people say oh you know what mike i got
three months of
you know i just lost my job i got three
months to uh you know of pay coming to
me
severance you know i need to learn how
to trade so i don't have to get another
job
well you're putting all that undue
pressure on yourself you know that's
that's not a good situation
you know i can teach you how to trade
but at the end of the day
you know trying to put all that weight
on your shoulders
isn't the best best scenario and but the
thing is with trading it's a skill that
you could take with you
everywhere right whether after you
retire
you know after you get out of school if
you want to
quit your job you know learn how to
trade and it's a skill you could take
with you forever
so again why are you here is because you
want to discover an easy way to use
order flow in your trading
you want to see what makes order flow so
different and more effective than
traditional market analysis
and you want to learn strategies that
traders are using right now in the
market
now for a lot of people they tell you
well you know order flow is about
reading the time and sales or
reading the depth of market right the
price ladder but honestly trying to
make sense of the time in sales you
can't it moves too fast for most people
to i'll say most people pretty much
everybody it just moves too fast
and a lot of small trades that really
confuse you and trying to read the depth
of market
you know the market conditions for the
last several years has been
very chaotic that trying to read a dome
and get anything meaningful out of it is
is not practical you know if you're
trading a slower market
you know wheat you know some of the
grains yeah the dome is incredibly
helpful but honestly trying to read a
dome
in the nasdaq or micro nasdaq forget
about it it's just
jumping around too fast for you so
everything that you see on a bar chart
comes from time and sales
right if you ever looked at a bar chart
you wonder
some people probably don't but all that
information that you see
comes from the time and sales it gives
you a lot of information right that's
why people say well you should look at
time and sales
because you can see where the aggressive
traders are coming in and hitting the
bid
you know when a market change from bid
to offer and so on but the problem is
it just moves too fast right everything
that you see on this
time and sales here that's all within
the same second
so you imagine you know you're really
breaking things down to
nanoseconds if you're trying to read
time and sales and you just can't
right it just moves too fast but if you
take that information and you put it in
a footprint chart
it gives you more information that you
can use
right you can see the delta the point of
control
the imbalances now again that's sort of
the gateway into understanding order
flow
is delta point of control and imbalances
and once you understand those three
points it's going to give you
a lot more ways of looking at the market
taking it apart and understanding
what's happening in the market so delta
is the difference between aggressive
buying and aggressive selling
now you know i know some people like to
argue that oh you know a market went up
because there's more buyers than sellers
well
no the market went up because there's
more aggressive buyers
than aggressive sellers right because
what is an aggressive buyer an
aggressive seller
now in the u.s right because of low
interest rates because of work from home
from anywhere
because of a lot of the stuff happening
in the big cities last year
with um looting and all that stuff
there's been a big migration out to the
suburbs
so now it's a seller's market to sell
your home so
perfect example right if you look for a
home in you know
outside of chicago in the suburbs
a home hits the market right half a
million dollars
now the seller lists his house at a half
a million dollars
the buyer now has to become aggressive
because property market is rising so he
just lifts the offer he just i'll pay
half a million dollars for this house
the buyer was aggressive the seller was
passive
right and so say that person buys that
house and the next house comes up oh
this house just sold for half a million
i could sell mine for 510. he lists his
house at 510 someone buys that
right so you have more aggressive buyers
than people coming in and
lowering the price of their house if the
seller comes in and lowers the price of
his house
he is being the aggressive seller right
because he will go down
say the buyer says you know i like your
half million dollar house but
i only think it's worth 480 so he bids
and the seller has to think well oh you
know my neighbor wants to sell his house
he's also going to be selling it at 500.
i got a buyer here
at 480 maybe you know i i want to
i just want to unload my house before
this before this buyer sees my
neighbor's house come up for sale for
half a million
and buys his instead so he knows he has
a bid at 480 but he's offering it at
500.
he goes down and says fine i'll sell it
to you at 480. now the seller
has become the aggressor right he is
aggressively selling his house to that
bidder
okay so that delta measures the
difference between the aggressive buying
and the aggressive selling
so like right now in the housing markets
you know if i were to measure the delta
i would say
it's positive you know whatever because
you have a lot of aggressive buyers
lifting the offer even paying in some
cases cash over
the price of the house all right and so
it's very aggressive market in terms of
buyers i mean there's a limited supply
of houses
that's why the price is going up now
point of control
is the price level in the bar with the
most volume
and that's important because in a bar
you know the level where everybody is
happy to trade at
is sort of the balance area of the bar
you know where most of the volume is
occurring
and you know people like to say well
volume doesn't really matter
right because obviously for every buyer
there's there's a seller but
if you've ever run a business you know
whether selling
things on ebay or you know an actual
brick and mortar store you understand
that
volume helps you determine your pricing
right because if you're raising your
price but you're selling less
you're going to be making less money so
you're going to be lowering your price
right you want to
find that sweet spot where you can sell
the most of your
supply at a fair price and think of it
in the market right you have buyers and
sellers you know people
that have supply and people that want to
buy that supply so
there's that equilibrium there's sort of
that that fine
sweet spot that the market will find
you know over if you're looking at one
minute bar you know over that's
60 seconds if you're looking at a five
minute over that five minute period 15
minute
there's always going to be that sweet
spot where everyone is sort of happy to
transact
right and that's what the market really
exists for is for people
to transact you know either to buy the
supply
sell their supply you know or transfer
risk you know at a level that's
that's fine you know like go out you you
need to buy insurance
right you can just go ask one agent
right and he'll tell you okay yeah you
know you want life insurance
for whatever a million dollar in policy
this is what it'll cost you
but if you're smart you know sometimes
you go out and you look at three or four
different
quotes right and you're going to find
the one that
is makes more sense to you price wise
right so you know you could have one guy
pricing your
insurance policy at 350
a month but then everybody else comes in
at you know
250 okay so the market is really valued
at 250 not necessarily 350.
now imbalances is
the areas the price levels rather where
aggressive buyers outnumber
aggressive sellers by a particular ratio
usually it's four to one
or more and
the way to think of this is you know
you're looking at sort of the
balance in the market okay so imagine
like me i've got three kids okay so i'm
an adult i've got three kids
you know four six and eight and if i
play tug of war with them it's
it's you know three against one but
you know maybe me against two you know i
might lose
but when you start adding in a third
you know then the mom joins in and it's
four to one against me
i i'll probably lose and that's how
imbalances are
it's when you have you know aggressive
buyers people
lifting the offer versus people hitting
the bid
you know outnumbering each other right
and aggressive sellers would be
you know you've got say 10 sellers
versus one buyer
right so the market is six bid at seven
but you have ten people buying it at
seven versus
one person selling it at six you would
consider that uh
buying a balance right because there's
only one seller at six
but you have 10 buyers at seven right
you have more people
aggressively buying than aggressively
selling
so remember right all the information
you see on your chart comes from what's
traded in the market
you know from what you see in the time
and sales now but a candlestick chart it
leaves out the most important part
of data that's available to the trader
the volume okay
and that's important and the reason you
know
as a trader you want to have as much
information as possible
right now people say well what about
information overload well
yeah you have a lot of information you
have to know how to use it
okay you have to understand what you're
looking at and
i'm gonna get that in a second but you
know you see the market all the time
right
market's moving it trades back to a
particular level and then it just takes
off
right this is yesterday in the gold
right we're sort of
moving up we pull back go back up pull
back
right at this level literally right to
this level well why
right maybe there's something you could
understand people say well yeah you have
a double bottom here
okay as you know they'll say that as you
hit this bottom and you're
you're breaking out to the upside but as
a trader right you wanna
if you can see that hey you know what i
have a double bottom
forming as it's forming and understand
why it's forming
you're gonna be way ahead by getting
long in here
then the people that are buying this
breakout up here
right you know that's that's a full
dollar
in the gold 10 ticks before everybody
realizes hey you know what we got a
double bottom here
okay and that's where something like the
point of control
is going to help you right and i
mentioned all right point of control is
the price level in a bar
with the most volume now every bar is
going to have a point of control
oftentimes it's going to be somewhere in
the middle of the bar towards the middle
of the bar
but there are times when certain points
of control matter
this is that area right down here this
double bottom right here these
the two green candles that follow the
big red candle down
okay and if you understand how to
use point of control that's going to put
you ahead of everybody else that's
waiting for the breakout to happen to
say this is a double bottom because you
can confirm this double bottom
pretty quick right as this bar is
forming as this bar closes
you can be getting long immediately in
the next bar
rather than waiting for so many bars to
happen
and you're breaking out of this high
because now you're anticipating
that hey you know what i have a double
bottom forming here
and you could position yourself to take
advantage of it so
in order flow like i said every bar has
a point of control but not every bar
matters
now the order flows trader software
will highlight to you the points of
control that matter
right it'll print it color it a
different color
every point of control would normally be
a gray color but software you could have
software that's going to highlight it at
different colors so you could just see
oh you know what
i've got a point of control that matters
we call these prominent points of
control
right if they're blue that's going to be
support
if it's a magenta color just like a
purple almost it will offer potential
resistance so i know
why this market came back here because i
hear i've got point of control right on
the bottom of this bar
that's a bullish sign in the market then
we come back to that level we test that
exact level that prominent point of
control that i had earlier
and the point of control this time is
one tick up off of that
um off that low but it's also a
prominent point of control so it's
telling me that
hey you know what these points of
control matter this is there was
something interesting
in the volume right that is telling you
that
hey you know what you have support here
so i know i've got support
as it's forming rather than waiting for
this market to break out i know already
yeah the order flow is telling me
there's some good buying
passive buying happening down here
and like i said if you're using just any
old software
the footprint chart you know whether
it's sierra charts or the ninjatrader
version of order flow or you know
there's a lot of other software out
there i can't
name them all but wouldn't it be easier
if you had software that would highlight
things that matter
like right like the points of control
because like i said every bar has a
point of control
right but not every point of control is
going to matter
so if you're doing it on your own you
know you can sort of figure it out
you'd have to look at a lot of charts to
understand what's going on
but if you have
software that's going to highlight it to
you it's just going to put you ahead of
everybody okay now here this is
mini nasdaq okay this is yesterday again
right similar right i showed you the
gold chart earlier
but if you're looking down here this is
actually
last night about 8 30 last night
you just sort of going sideways in here
okay
and then the market rallies right it
rallies up from
you know the 14 15 16 area all the way
up into the 30s
okay but if you're looking at the order
flow you can start to see
you know what i've got some prominent
points of control in here
right but you have to know what to look
for to see a prominent point of control
right right here this this blue point of
control is telling you
that it's prominent it's an area that we
had been going sideways now we're really
starting to build up the volume in here
right so that's why understanding where
prominent points of control
come in is going to put you ahead of
everybody because
if you're just going sideways in here
right
just sideways you're wondering well
maybe we're consolidating and then we'll
fall off
or you know maybe if we start rallying
you know where are you going to be
looking to buy you know
because you know people like to try and
buy a breakout but
we're sort of just sold off you know
and if you're buying it here after a
strong sell-off
sometimes it's not the the most prudent
move out there
but if you can see something in the
order it tells you hey you know what
there's some volume in here pay
attention to it
you're willing to take that risk right
you're willing to get long around the
area with a stop just below this volume
at 06
right so imagine you're getting
you're getting in here all right you're
getting
in you know after this bar closes
somewhere around 13
14 with a stop around 6
five or six you know what is that that's
you know
eight points and then what
12 you get in 12 13 it rallies all the
way up into the 30s
you know so you're risking seven eight
points for
you know 25 basically 25
you know even at um even if you just get
out up here at 24
you know you've doubled your money all
right you went for you got in at 12 or
13 you're out at
23 24 that's 10 ticks you've only risked
seven ticks okay if you held it longer
better they held it a little bit longer
even better so
you know that's where using the order
flow is going to give you that sort of
that head start over
everybody else because you know at a
minimum they're waiting for this
breakout up here at 17.
but you could be getting in here you
know around 12 13
14 ahead of everybody
see this point of control matters right
yeah i said you have a lot of points of
control every bar has a point of control
but not everyone matters okay you see
well you know points of control are
going higher
okay one two three four points of
control higher well isn't that bullish
right the market's going up
yeah the market is going up but at some
point
you know markets don't go up
indefinitely at some point
things are going to start to change and
if you have something that's going to
highlight
to you that um you know that things are
going to change
it's just going to put you ahead of
everybody else out there right rather
than
oh i know things have changed here sort
of at this high
the swing high rather than let it come
off
then you start um you know
breaking down and then you're getting
short down here at 42 42 and a half 43
where would you rather be short from up
here around the 44 44 and a half area
or 42 42 and a half you know you want
those clues to happen
as soon as possible
so taking it sort of
the next step okay point of control
right point of control
is volume right it's the point in the
bar with the most volume
now in the new version of
order flows trader the version we
released back in october
you know we've gone through this is the
the third
version since 2015 you know we're
upgrading our software
with new tools for traders one of the
things that we added
was the bar value now most people
understand
the value areas because you know they've
done analysis
or they've done reading and research on
market profiles so they understand
you know sort of the value area right
and that's the area
in the in the profile where about you
know 70 percent
some people use 68 of the volume occurs
in the day's trading but you could take
it a step further
right you could do it on a bar by bar
basis
sort of the the area of the bar where 70
of the volume traded now you could
actually you could adjust it right so
you want to look at
you know i just want to see the area
where um 50
of the volume traded or even you know 33
percent you can adjust that
but the standard is 70 percent
and when you start looking at the value
as well as points of control and other
things that i'll get to
in a little bit later you really start
to break down the market and understand
what's happening
right so here's a market that had been
going up right this bigger
gray area right the darker gray is the
point of control
but this bigger gray area is the value
so you have a value area high
and a value area low obviously the point
of control of the bar
but as you see these bars going up
right you're seeing value basically
moving higher value area is going up
up up but then you see all of a sudden
everything just changes in this bar
right here right you want to understand
you know as a trader you want to
get in on the turn as quickly as
possible
now we start going down you can see now
the value is going down right you even
have a gap
in the value area between this bar and
this bar
right you even got a gap down here
between this bar and this bar
but what about the value is there's
value
excuse me is there value in the value
area so to speak
well yes there is because there's times
that the value area is expanding sort of
in the opposite direction to what had
just happened right imagine we just have
this nice move up
right value area is going up for the
most part you do pull back a little bit
then it
corrects and keeps going back up but
what if there was a way
that you can see easily see that hey you
know what
the value in the bar has changed right
it's telling me something
bearish right i do have a bearish
prominent point of control
okay but what else if i you know what
else can i use
rather than just the point of control
you could use the value area
all right so imagine here you have the
market moving up
and it turned right in this bar now
we're starting to see
bearish point of control we're starting
to see it bearish value area was what
happened value area opened up
above the previous value area and closed
well below it
right it's almost an engulfing value
area so to speak
right but it's a shift in the value area
obviously the bar is heading down
next bar opens up inside that value area
immediately trades away from it that's
also bearish right so when you
understand
value and how it's happening in the
market
you can start to see things changing in
the market that other people aren't
okay this is just your your normal
footprint chart
okay it just looks okay yeah yeah i can
see points of control
go you know market showed grinding it's
way higher right so we're going sideways
down here
come up a little bit go sideways some
more go up a little bit
and then finally get that pop but if
you're looking at value
you could see here right you're in this
sideways activity
value area is telling you hey you know
what
we're expanding right value is getting
bigger and as value expands
right the markets is starting to look
for
sort of a different balance area a new
balance area
so you can see we're just going sideways
now we start expanding okay we find our
new balance area
then again you see the bullish expanding
the bullish eva we call them um
we call them evas so you can see here
right it's also bullish we got one down
here one over here
and the market goes up but this was the
clue right if you're just looking at a
normal
footprint chart here you know you sort
of say well yeah i can sort of see it
you know sort of moving up here
right we're sort of going sideways in
the points of control we got some
positive delta
and okay you know you're probably
willing to
get long somewhere around the 41 but if
you're looking at the value areas you
can have noticed
earlier here you know you'd be getting
long at 39
39 and a half even 40 rather than
waiting
all the way up here to 41 to to really
feel confident because now you're seeing
the value areas
starting to expand so that's on a one
minute chart right but
about other chart types is a five minute
chart i use mostly
e-mini's because that's the market most
people trade
but again i'll show you other markets as
well um
and i show minute-based charts sometimes
i show
range based charts volume-based charts
but again it's not like you got to have
20 different charts open you you
the same things you would look for
whether it's a minute based chart or
range based chart a volume based chart
it applies right all those different
types of
chart types so here this is yesterday
right we sold off if you remember around
11 30 down to around the 52 area
and then we rallied okay but what is
that you know people say well
you got a pin bar here you know etc you
know i love these guys that
live and die by pin bars because when
they work they're like oh yeah look at
me i'm a genius but
you know they they fail as often as they
work if not more
but if you start adding value
right you can see that on the sell-off
here you got a bearish eva here
right at the 63 area right you just
you're selling off
going sideways it's just sitting in here
then boom you're seeing the value area
get strong negative right and then you
sell off you get down here
yeah you have your pin bar down to 53 so
imagine you're getting short somewhere
in here 61
62 you get a move 10 move down the the
50s 52 53
then you start coming back up now you
could also use
you know for a lot of people you know
back in the days when they were
trading pits right the markets would
open and close and then nothing would
happen until the next day so there was a
lot of
analysis with gaps you know gap analysis
theory
and people still trade gaps in things
like stocks
but you know if you trade forex if you
trade
crypto if you trade um obviously
futures you don't see much gaps
right especially if you because the
markets trade basically continuously
but when you start looking at value
right you can see
gaps in the value right so here right
this market is coming down
down down down and then it starts
reversing as you're starting to go
up right you have a gap here between
this
green bar and this green bar in the
value if you're just looking at where
bars open and close you're not going to
see gaps
but when you're looking at value you
start to see gaps and that just opens up
a whole other form of analysis for you
is that gap analysis
because things are important right
there's so much analysis that can be
done with value that it just really
is is quite amazing you know we're just
sort of scratching the surface on it
because nobody's really ever thought
about it looking at it on a bar by bar
basis but
you know imagine this green this red
candle right here okay
what happened okay well let me stick
with this green candle here
so you're coming down selling off okay
and at this time early in this bar
the value area is obviously below the
value or the previous bar
and early in this bar it's a big red
candle down so the value is is
lower right there's a gap because we
never went in and
even into the previous value area but
the bar turned around turned green
closed
next bar open so you have your value
area high here at 39 55 and a quarter
right the next bar opens in the value
trades in that value right it comes
literally almost to the value area low
and then it rallies back up
okay and and also that tells you
something
but this bar forms the value area here
is higher than the value area here right
and that's important
this one i'm not putting i'm not really
using this in my
analysis because yeah we gap down those
are green candles so now
i'd be position thinking in my head
where's the market going to gap up
right it you know or is it going to gap
up okay
you see the gap up here gap up here
right
that that tells you value is moving
higher right and that's important
now another form of analysis is when you
open up
outside of the previous bar's value
right do you
trade all the way through it you trade
into it
you know and you know if you understand
market profile you understand that
if you open above value and you start
trading into value
there's a chance you could get all the
way through that value and compete
continue in that direction as you see
here right we opened above
previous bars value area traded into it
accepted it
got all the way through to the other
side and just pushed much lower
so there's all sorts of analysis you can
do with value areas
so hopefully by now you can start to
understand how it becomes easier to
trade
order flow when your software helps you
do analysis right
so how much easier do you think your
trading will become when you
add in order flow analysis to it right
we we tend to make trading
and things in general more complicated
than it really needs to be
so the next thing i'll talk about is
imbalances right and i've mentioned
earlier what an imbalance is and when
you have
more than one imbalance in a bar you
really got to start paying attention
now most traders are familiar with
stacked imbalances right people always
talked about stacked imbalances
for a long time in the order flow right
and what stacked imbalances here you
have
three imbalances stacked nice and neatly
on top of each other right eight against
11 against 123 83 against 384
okay that's nice right then the market
you know sort of trading right or
rotating around
that aggressive selling before it
finally sold off
now this is a silent balance is
obviously eight against 72 it's about
nine to one 11 against 123 that's about
10 to 1.
83 against 384 you know that's about
four to one so
depending on the imbalances that you're
using
you know the ratio whether it's four to
one five to one three to one
is going to tell you if there's an
imbalance at a particular price level
just like this green bar you have two
buying imbalances you got zero against
you got 11 against 435. if it's a blue
number
in the order flow that's a buying and
balance if it's a red number that's
assigned a bounce
and oftentimes bars either have a buying
or selling a balance at some point
right but when you start to see a bunch
of them you know that's when you got to
really be paying attention because it's
telling you
traders are getting aggressive right now
right so here's a stacked buying
imbalance okay
you know market has just been going
sideways you start to see a little bit
of selling you got is selling a balance
here
one here two here but then it came back
with a stack buying a balance right one
against 39 90 against 42
52 against 371 and then it took off to
the upside right because
as you're going sideways you know you
had some aggressive selling but then it
came right back with that aggressive
buying that sort of kicked off this
rally
right so knowing where this aggressive
buying and aggressive selling
is coming in at more than just one level
is going to be important
now while stacked imbalances are nice
there's also bars that have multiple
imbalances that
aren't neatly stacked on top of each
other are they not important right
yeah it's very easy to see optically a
stacked
buying a balance right or a stacked
selling imbalance but
there's going to be bars where they're
not neatly stacked on top of each other
right the market isn't always
neat right it's messy at times but that
doesn't mean that
a bar that has many buying imbalances
isn't as important as a bar that has a
stacked bind and balance
right and again this is
this is this morning um in the e-minis
right here
right we hit this low this is about 8 40
you know 10 minutes after the cash open
came down to 39 30 and a quarter going
sideways
but then you're starting to see a bar
with three imbalances one two three
okay now is that important or not
important well to me it's i found it's
very important and
it's followed up by another bar with
three buying imbalances
one two three right so imagine you're at
your low of the day
and you're starting to see the
aggressive buyers wake up and come into
the market right so
if you're looking for stacked buying and
balances
you don't see a stack buying a balance
here because they're sort of spread out
here you don't see a stack buying a
balance because they're spread out
right you got 24 against 102 that's the
imbalance 50 against 80. that's not a
binding balance
one against 48 that's in balance one
against 166.
it's also a binary balance right so even
in here you've got
three imbalances but down here you have
also
three imbalances if you're just looking
for stacked imbalances you're going to
miss this trade
right and again it went up from 32 33
all the way up to 40. right before you
what you ran into
a bearish prominent point of control
even on this side here you gotta stack
selling a balance
this is a five-minute chart okay and
again your market's coming down you're
seeing some selling and balances in here
one two three four five six and balance
is there
one two three four imbalances here but
your market's selling off that's what
you're expecting to see but then we hit
a low
the market starts turning around
one two three buying imbalances one two
three buying imbalances
okay but if you know that you want to
look for them yeah you can see them
but again i have software that's going
to highlight it to you
our software puts a nice box around it
now you will say we have sound and
balances here when you're talking about
that well yeah we're selling off we're
selling into the lows that's what you're
expecting to see
but as you hit the low and you start
rallying you want to be aware
of are their buying imbalances you know
are they spread out
okay here right say
you missed this trade like well i don't
know if it's strong enough by the time
you get in here
yeah okay the aggressive buyers are
present there's no
denying that right and the market
rallies you know from 24 all the way
back up
and again
if you're looking at a chart bar chart
you're not going to see this information
on there right you're just basically
guessing you know is there aggressive
buying in here well i got a big green
bar up
and you know it's green bar you know
people must be aggressively buying it
here
you know or people get some red bars you
know people are selling yeah well yeah
of course but
is it market balanced or is it
imbalanced right i mean you had
opportunity to buy here
right market went up a little bit then
sold off why did this
move work better than this move right if
you bought it here
you probably got stopped out but if you
bought it in here
you know you had the first leg up you
pull back a little bit you got a nice
second leg all the way back up you know
there 10 points here but you really want
to be watching what's happening
in the market so remember
trading the market is not just about
watching price movement there are many
different moving parts to the market
right are there imbalances what's
happening in point of control
um delta you have to be using them
and looking at price go up or down is
not really giving you a full story you
can't survive trading a single market
perspective and what that means is you
can't survive just trading price now i
know there's people out there that are
successful trading price action
but they are very focused and
honestly most traders aren't as focused
as that
but why limit yourself to just price
right there's a whole other realm
of information out there that you know
you just turn the page and you can see
things that are happening that other
traders aren't
right you have to integrate that
information that market generated
information into your trading
you know what the aggressive traders are
doing you know how's the market reacting
to that aggressive trading
and going back to this chart right
what's going on down here
versus down here what makes this one so
much better than this one
well if you look at the footprint this
is the first
low here okay yeah i see one aggressive
buyer here
let's see two aggressive buyers a little
bit of aggressive buying but not much
right that's why this move just sort of
petered out
and then fell over but this move down
here
the second part right that's
this low down here where
this was the low that started this big
move up from 40s all the way up to 60s
what do we see we're starting to see
imbalances buying and balance buying in
bed you know then three up here
this is a stacked imbalance you got
another one down here
so you not only have a stacked imbalance
but you also got other imbalances in the
bar
right the buying balances are coming in
the aggressive buyers are coming into
the market
right it's easy to miss if you're just
looking
at imbalances
right because you got to be paying
attention let software
highlight it to you let it come in and
say hey you know what i've got a bar
here
with multiple imbalances now this is a
stacked imbalance so it would show up as
a stacked imbalance i have it turned off
actually
but if you're looking at stacked
imbalances you'd see it okay fine
but over here right another bar with
multiple imbalances so you know this
move
has got the strength that you need to go
higher
so you know even if you know it's scary
sometimes trying to buy a low
right and i'm not trying to predict the
low i'm letting the market tell me hey
you know what this is the low based on
the information at hand
then it starts moving up maybe you want
a little bit more confirmation
bang you get that confirmation right
here with another bar
with a bunch of buying and balances
right this is
yesterday right remember we were testing
that high of the day right we came all
the way back up to
70 and a half our high was 70 and three
quarters
you got a bearish prominent point of
control right here
and it's just like you know are we going
higher are we going to come off
okay and again it's like i said it's
it's a tough trade trying to sell a high
or buy a low sometimes because you know
you're basically standing in front of a
freight train right if the market's been
going up and you're trying to get short
mark you could
sell off a little bit then turn around
and just run you over but if you start
looking at the order flow
right what the aggressive sellers are
doing if you're at a high
then boom right you can see right if
you're not noticing if you're not really
paying attention
to what aggressive sellers are coming in
right when you see it right here one two
three imbalances
it's a little hard to notice right
because you know the market's trading
right and and things are happening
very quickly but having software that's
going to highlight say hey
you know what i got a bar here pay
attention to this then you start looking
back say oh you know what i had a
bearish problem point of control here
we're up at the high of the day i know i
got resistance based on the point of
control
also now i see aggressive sellers coming
in yeah okay i could get short this
market
and you get short you know from the 67
area and just it just sells off nicely
into
you know a quick it's a one minute chart
one two three four
five five minutes five points
so that's imbalances
that is points of control volume
value now what about weakness in the
markets
right what can you what how can you see
areas where the market is weak
right would you like to know when a move
up is weakening or when a move down is
weakening when that move down is losing
its strengths
because when markets lose their strength
right when moves lose their strength
that's when reversals can happen and not
only that but
in directional moves right often have
you have directional moves then the
market sort of goes sideways right then
you're starting to think well
is this move over or are we going to put
a second leg in
or are we going to reverse right so that
is where
the third part of sort of the order flow
foundation comes in and that's delta
right when traders first come to order
flow you know
one of their first exposures to order
flow is the delta
okay and delta is the difference between
net aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers in a bar
right but the problem is you learn about
delta
but then you don't learn how to use it
okay
and what's what's the point is you know
you can probably figure it out on your
own after a long time of studying the
markets but
again you can you find yourself going
down a lot a lot of
paths that lead nowhere let the computer
analyze this stuff for you let the
computer analyze the order flow for you
now again this was yesterday's highlight
what i just talked about
with the bearish prominent point of
control with the selling
multiple selling imbalances but right
here
right just a few ticks off our high of
the day we're seeing
market weakness right we're seeing this
move up weakening
and that's important information so you
start putting it together well you know
i got a bearish point of control i got
resistance here
i've got aggressive sellers here and
i've got
weakness here right and weakness is the
aggressive buying
has weakened to a point where the
aggressive buyers just aren't
active that much anymore right and when
you remove that buying pressure from a
market that's been going up
right it goes up because you got more
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
but now aggressive buyers
are being removed from the market then
what do you think the market's going to
do
can it still go up well yeah there's
still some potentially aggressive buyers
but when it gets weakened to a certain
level the market's not going to sustain
that move anymore
right and what's the next step well the
next step is if you remove those buyers
that move up isn't going to be very
strong
the market's just going to naturally
collapse on its own i want to say
collapse but
go down on its own okay so that's that's
important
as a trader to understand where those
levels are
and again if you're just looking at a
normal bar chart
you can't see all right you can't see
that this move has weakened you can't
see
the resistance up here in the point of
control you can't see the aggressive
sellers coming in there
right you're just left to guessing it
you just say well oh yeah
this looks bullish actually because what
you have happened here is you hit the
high
you sold off you probe down here then
you start coming up you got a big
aggressive bar
up right then you start trading higher i
think oh this is it we're breaking out
we're going to hit new highs new
all-time highs and go higher
but if you're looking at the order flow
what's happening in here it's actually
very bearish
right you got market weakness you got a
bearish primary point of control telling
you there's resistance up here
obviously you got the multiple
imbalances here
and we sold off you know where are we
trading now uh i don't know my chart
open but
where are we trading you know this
morning we're trading in the 20s
it's 50 points lower you know what about
this low here
okay this was yesterday right all the
way you know 11 30 we hit this low at 53
then we rally up
all the way back up into the 70s uh not
70s but to the 60s
okay well why because on that move down
this move down was weakening all right
wouldn't you like to know that hey you
know we have this
sharp sell-off but as we're just putting
in these newer lows it's getting weaker
right and once you remove those sellers
from the market once that
selling pressure is alleviated what's
the natural
order of the market to do well it's to
go back up
right so you got that strong selling
down in here but it's
turned and went higher why is because
that selling pressure has been
taken out of the market it's gone it's
exhausted itself it's sort of run
through its course
right and that's where having software
that's going to highlight it to you
that's this
blue up arrow is going to help you as a
trader
now what it does and how it works is by
reading the delta
right is delta
getting weaker right as you're going
down right is the delta weakening if
you're looking at a normal bar chart
you don't even look know what delta is
because you don't even have access to
delta information on a normal bar chart
but if you're looking at order flow the
transactions that go through
you can see the delta right you can see
it weakening here it's
9 positive 9 positive 5 minus 400
okay that's strong but then minus 300
then minus 81.
right it's weakened all right where's
the strong selling
here you got some strong selling here
you got some strong selling these two
bars
you got nothing basically delta's at
zero
nine and five that's basically nothing
here's 81
right so the selling for this move to
happen can continue going down
you need a strong aggressive selling
then instead you see
strong aggressive buying to the upside
500 delta
786 delta right
crude oil yesterday right we had that
nice big sell-off here
right at eight o'clock right but
you know you want to have some sort of
clue earlier
you know preferably you know here but if
not here
maybe even higher up here right because
we have the swing high around what is
that about 7
13 yesterday 7 15.
we came off right this is that area
right here 7 15 in the morning yesterday
this is this right in here okay
but you can see this market weakness
right the market had been
sort of trending a little bit higher you
know you got a
high here then you got a
a higher low higher high higher low
higher high right that's that's your
wave analysis
right you're putting in higher highs but
at this higher high
you see weakness come into the market
right that's not what you want to see at
a higher high
right for the market to go higher you
want to see strong
buying right but you just see how this
this delta is very weak you know you're
coming up here you got
negative delta you're sort of working
your way higher negative delta
then even the delta that you're coming
into these highs yeah it's 38
okay and 16 12 that's nothing as you're
coming into this
higher high and you know
at this point you're trading what 64 70
64 68
right and then what happens it's right
here right boom market sells off
from you know the 64 65 area all the way
down to
45 area it does pull back a little bit
before it drops now again
i'm not saying you could have caught
this drop but this move right here
is 20 cents is easy an easy trade to
take
ultra bonds okay great contract to trade
if you're not familiar with ultra bonds
ub is the symbol but what's happened
here
right you start putting these pieces
together that i was just explaining you
know a point of control that matters
prominent bearish prior point of control
multiple imbalances market weakness
right and market sells off
right this was ultra bonds as well right
you come into a swing low
you don't have any prominent point of
control but now you're getting multiple
binding balances
and then you're starting to see the
market weakness in the sense now when
you
it's a little confusing for people when
you hear the term market weakness
and you're looking to buy what it is is
the selling weakness the selling
is getting weaker right and as as you're
coming off that high
putting in a swing low starting to see
the aggressive buying
but as well
of the aggressive buying in here with
the imbalances
that aggressive selling that you had
seen earlier is is gone
right that's your weakness right now
it's a bullish signal that's why there's
that blue arrow
soybeans right
yesterday right we're coming off you got
your first sign here
okay mark it just goes sideways then
boom
the bar that has market weakness right
telling you the selling has
um basically over sort of played its
hand
then you got in that same bar you've got
multiple buying imbalances
right and the market works its way back
up
e-mini five-minute chart again
yesterday this was that one right this
was the bearish eva in this bar here
you got your pin bar here but you can
see as this move
is happening the selling is getting
weaker right it's 1100
strong negative 1600 strong negative
then 300
negative then again another minus 306
right it's also negative delta but it's
not strong
right people say well and then you see
even in this bar it turns up
people are going to be scratching their
head i got negative delta but i got a
green candle
right shouldn't it be a positive delta
right it's a green candle well not
necessarily
right in this bar there's some strong
volume on the mid side so there was some
support to absorb
that selling that came in there so even
though you have a green candle with
negative delta
that's often a sign of absorption and
that absorption is also measured
in the weakness because as the market's
coming down if you have somebody
absorbing
that selling well if you know about
absorption right people are selling into
that
into those buyers then finally all those
sellers are
pretty much done they're removed from
the market and once those sellers are
removed what happened right the market
went back
up again you know e-mini five minutes
yesterday or sorry the 15th monday
the market just sort of going sideways
not really putting in direction
and then what happens you know as you're
going sideways the seller's just
basically you know what we're fed up
we've been selling it
and we can't get the market to move now
they're done
right they got no more bullets left
right and then you got the weakness in
the sellers
which turns into bullish for the buyers
and the market put in a nice
a nice 15 point rally right
e-minis again yes also on monday
right you can see it here we just sort
of open up cash open and just sort of go
sideways
but you're not seeing that aggressive
buying anymore
right after the open right you just
monday was kind of a tricky day
um you know you get these bars that just
sort of
you know they're not doji you know
they're not bars that you open and close
at the same level but
you know you got nice ranges but in the
markets looking for its direction
okay but what it's telling you is you
know we just opened up we got buying and
selling but now
that aggressive buying is just sort of
dried up right it's done
right the the algos sort of ran through
their orders that they had to fill on
the cash open
and now that that buying pressure has
been removed and you can see the market
just trades
down about 10 points now what's
interesting is you can adjust the
strength
of the weakness levels that you're
looking at
so you can see it happening a little bit
early
now you know if you dressed it to a to a
i'm not a weaker level but a less
stronger level than sort of the default
you're going to get a lot more signals
but
it's important especially on
moves that are happening okay i mean is
there a difference between getting short
off this bar or this one probably not in
the grand scheme of things but where
adjusting the strength can help you
is indirectional moves right i'll move
up that sort of just stalls and goes
sideways
but you know on a move up why does the
market often
stone go sideways is because you could
have profit taking people
that were long earlier are getting out
here okay fine
they get out that doesn't mean the move
is over because they're still
buying pressure in there it's just that
that that little bit of selling pressure
people taking their profits
once people have got out took their
profits oftentimes you're going to see
the move
continue back up right and what's
interesting in this move is
again you're seeing the weakness in that
selling pressure but then you're seeing
the aggressive buying come right back up
so you start putting the two pieces
together
the week in weakening aggressive selling
followed by strong aggressive buying
what do you think the market's going to
going to do right it's going to keep
going up now
you know being a trader it's about
understanding what's happening in the
market right it's not about
necessarily buying every single
blue arrow or bar with multiple
imbalance right you want to
put it in context with what's happening
in the market
right like you get to think you know
i know some people don't want to and you
know fine i can respect that
they want to have you know computer
automate everything well honestly if
that's the case just give your money to
a money manager
um but if you want to trade you know the
big money is made from making
good trading decisions right and leaving
it up to
a black box you know isn't always the
best
route to go okay so understanding what's
happening
in the markets you know i is really
going to put you ahead of
everybody else out there right that's
just relying on some
red light and green light system you
know by truly understanding oh
i know that aggressive selling is
weakening here and i see aggressive
buying is coming in
that's going to put you ahead of
everybody else right that's your edge in
the market
so imagine where you could be in your
trading once you're able to put the
pieces of order flows together
right well everyone else is still
thinking does this point of control
matter
what's happening in the delta what's
happening in the balance imbalances
you'll know right instead of trying to
figure it out because you got
software that will tell you that hey you
know what this point of control matters
hey you know what you've got a bar with
a bunch of buying imbalances or a bar
with a bunch of sauna balances
and you know what's happening in delta
are is the aggressive buying weakening
is the aggressive selling weakening
right so today i showed you how to use
prominent point of control
value areas extended value areas
multiple imbalances
market weakness and you know these are
just tools that are available
in the order flows trader software now
again i sort of
talked a bit about how you can see it on
your own
by using you know just a plain footprint
chart i used to do that
right it's these use a plain footprint
chart to trade
and it it took me a long time right i've
been
involved in trading electronic markets
literally since
the 90s you know i don't see the
beginning because they had been around
for
a year or two before i left the trading
floor to
to focus solely on the electronic
markets but
i've been looking at a dome for you know
over 25 years i've been looking at time
and sales for over 25 years and these
are things that
i would look for and i've applied it to
my trading right so again don't just go
out there
and start trading every single order
flow
prominent point of control or extended
value area or multiple imbalance that
appears
put it in context of the market right
you got to read what's happening in the
market
and you know understand it right i mean
just like being a doctor
right you know you know how to operate
you know based on a book right oh you
got to cut here and do that but then
you know sometimes you cut you know
doctor cut some place and blood starts
squirting out right you have to be able
to adjust for that
okay so trading context of the market
right that's what being a trader is
so hopefully you've seen how order flow
just blows up a normal candlestick chart
right what attracted to me the order
flow years ago
was being able to understand who's in
control of the market
to be in sync with the market to know
why the market stops and reverses
and again what i showed you can be done
by just by looking at any footprint
chart
but you need to know what to look for
and when to look for it
where to look for in the chart you know
at highs or lows or
are you in a move and honestly when the
market's moving especially
how it is recently on days where the
market's down hard
it's easy to overlook things and miss
right let the software
do the heavy lifting for you let it show
you things in the order flow
like market weakness right so you can
concentrate more on managing the trade
than trying to think should i even take
this trade
and again you know order flows about
understanding what the traders are doing
in the market what the other traders are
doing in the market right takes all this
information from the time and sales and
processes it
into an easy to read format right don't
make trading more difficult
than it needs to be right again you know
as humans we tend to make
life more difficult for ourselves than
it needs to be
so hopefully you know this past hour or
so you'll agree that it's been time well
spent but again i can't cover
everything in a 60-minute session right
but i got a special offer for you that
you can get
everything you need to know about order
flow right if you act fast and give you
a special deal it's the order flows
trader
and it runs on ninjatrader eight it
doesn't run on sierra chart doesn't run
on tradestation
it runs on ninjatrader okay so it will
run on the free or paid version
and it's the volume footprint chart that
has 17 pre-programmed order full tools i
talked about a few today i talked about
multiple imbalances
i talked about primary point of control
i talked about
about market weakness but there's a lot
of other tools right there's obviously
the value area the extended value area
there is market sweep detector there's
imbalance reversals
there's a new thing that we have it's
called order flow sequencing
um and there's inverse imbalance there's
zero prints there's market exhaustion
there's a lot of different tools
and it's very easy to set up it takes
about two minutes to set up there's no
need for fancy templates or anything
and normally the price is 8.99 okay
and imagine it's like taking everything
that i know about trading with order
flow and put it into a program so that
you'll see what the institutional
traders are doing in the market
and i can say that because i was an
institutional trader for
close to two decades right and that's
important because
you know i see a lot of people teaching
order flow and stuff like that that
they've never sat on a trading desk
right they they've
they got into trading and then they
started learning about order flow
either from me or from other people and
like oh you know what i'm going to start
teaching order flow
when they've never put in the time
to really bang away at the market
in the sense of understanding order flow
they're just basically taking things and
regurgitating it
but i realize that having order flow is
one thing having software is one thing
you need to know how to use it so i
don't give you software and say here you
go figure it out
because that's how it used to be right
honestly it used to be
you would buy software for how many
thousands of dollars
but then it's just like here it is go
figure it out and then you're sitting
there scratching your head
trying to make sense of it and and i i
don't like that
right even for me like when i buy
software i don't want
to spend a lot of time trying to figure
it out um you know on on how to use it
effectively
right and i'll see you know i mean
people today we got less patience it
seems
so that's why i provide a lot of
education on how to trade with order
flow so you don't have to keep
um spending time and say oh does this is
this important is that important
i want to give you my order flow trading
course for free it's
15 hours of video instruction now a lot
of people have taken this course and
pirated it copied it you know and said
oh look you know
i'm an orderful trader now and basically
they teach you the same thing in the
course but i'm the one that created the
course
right it's um i sell this for 297 on my
website
you're gonna get it today for free okay
but also
i have a few years ago more than a few
years ago i
created an inner circle for people that
really wanted to
understand order flow more deeply okay i
created this
inner circle and i've extracted the
videos from it
right there's 56 videos that you're
going to get access to
and normally i sell just that video
portion of it for 4.97
okay and it's advanced order flow tricks
i like to call it tricks but tips and
analysis
okay so you can get the course you're
going to get
this inner circle video series right
plus the software
and already that's almost 1700 but
again you can spend all the time you
want trying to learn
from videos reading books
i also have a weekly live group training
session
okay where you could come in
and ask me questions i'll talk about
interesting things i saw in the overflow
like
um yesterday there was some nice big
volume in the market you know at
a particular level and i talked about
why that
why that was important and
it's an area where you could come in and
you know listen right ask questions
about anything right about the software
saying oh mike you know i don't
understand what
the function what you know this uh
indicator
is about right you know mark order flow
sequencing well i'll explain it to you
but it's a resource out there that you
can go now the slide says there's 92.
there's actually over 111
113 episodes you've been doing this for
over two years already
right and if you can't attend again it's
every tuesday night
at uh 7 p.m it runs for about an hour or
so but again
you're welcome to come in and join or if
you can't join you'll get access to the
replay
so you could watch it at your your own
pace but
you know it's a great resource again say
you're trying to reach me over email or
something and you couldn't reach me
you can reach me there i'm always there
because it's just me
in the room with you know everybody that
wants to come in right
so and it's just for our users so
you're able to ask anything you want
right
next week i'll be talking about
cumulative delta right and how to read
cumulative delta and and be useful about
it right and
it's again it's a place that if you're
struggling with your trading
or struggling trying to understand
orderful for you to come in and ask
questions
right i i don't do one-to-one
anymore um i've offered it in the past
you know like
one-to-one mentoring but honestly it's
quite expensive but i wanted to have
something where people could come in
and sort of interact and ask questions
um
and reach out to me for whatever reason
okay now of course i'm still available
over emails you know you can always
question
send me questions over emails but you
know i'm there and you'll get an answer
instantly for the most part unless it's
a very complex question
that would take me an hour i i have to
either
email you an answer or do a cover it on
the next
session but other software companies
they want to charge you for that
right they say oh yeah here's our
software and then a week later
while you're still trying to figure it
out you get another email oh we're
having a
boot camp for 9.99
you'll learn how to use our software
effectively well for what i just bought
your software
now you're charging me on on how to use
it you know how to learn how to use it
for what that that's ridiculous
again you know some people charge 200 a
month for
a room just like this you know they'll
say oh you know join our club
and you know 9 299 199 a month recurring
forever that you can't cancel
um and it's only one session a week
maybe two sessions a month
you know for what you know here it's for
free you know you get access to that
so you start adding it all up and it
gets you know it's close to two thousand
dollars but you're not going to pay that
right it's just going to be a one-time
payment of 7.49 now i got to be i'll be
honest with you this price is going up
um the end of this week
it's not going to be 7.49 it's going up
um
you know we've kept it down for we try
to keep it down as as long
as possible but um it's
it's going up and just go to
orderflows.com
off three there's no recurring payments
you know i hate that you know i see
software out there there's some software
i do want to buy sometimes and
it's on this recurring model oh you know
you sign up for it
you think well 79 a month 99
a month ah that's that's nothing then
you know you go in
later you don't like it you want to
cancel it you can't
you think you cancelled it then you're
still getting charged you even close the
charge
you know the credit card come you know
that you have and then you're still
getting charged somehow because it's
somehow linked to your bank account
that's so frustrating i hate that um
that's why
we just have a one-time payment of 7.49
now you're still going to need to pay
your data fees obviously
you don't need level two you just need
level one um
you know if you have a brokerage account
you can get it at pretty
inexpensive prices and obviously if
you're going to use the paid version of
ninjatrader you got to pay for that but
this will run on the free version of
ninjatrader so if you're using
you know another system for your order
entry you just get the free version a
ninjatrader
get some quotes fed into it and run my
software on it
so again you know what other people are
saying about the software
you know it's remarkably helpful sheila
writes because
she can clearly see what's happening in
the market right
that's what you want right you want to
be able to understand what's happening
in the market
so what you do is you go to order
flows.com off three
it's in the chat box there okay
scroll down the page now you can watch
the video and read the charts and all
that
but you get started just click this
button that says
click here that's going to get you
started
takes you to paypal paypal processes
your payment i don't get your
credit card information i don't want
that it's done through paypal
and you know after buying it go
check your email right it'll take some
time for paypal to process it but
and generate you know the license tokens
and and things like that and and course
logins
but it's going to be sent to your paypal
email address so again it's just a
one-time payment
of 7.49 so go to off order flows dot com
slash off
three dot html so you can ask yourself
right
imagine you know last year is about the
time that we started this all these
lockdowns around the world
right where are you now in your trading
versus where you are
a year ago are you still in the same
spot right you can stay where you are
and and go nowhere right by doing
nothing
or you can take some of what you've
learned today
and go out there and try and apply it on
your own
okay there's nothing wrong with that it
could work trial and error for the next
few months and perhaps if you're lucky
you start to see some positive results
you may not realize that you're putting
the cart before the horse
so to speak instead of behind the horse
but
the next option is to take action
right put the ball in the back of the
net right
you can let me take your hand and walk
you step by step through each part of
the process skip that trial and error
right if you do the work again you know
remember trading
being a successful trader does involve
work any line of
business any profession you got to put
in effort
right it does things just don't
magically fall into your lap yeah sure
you hear
stories of that happening to people but
those are rare right
in general you got to put in some effort
right to see some results
so figure out what motivates you right
maybe you want freedom to do what you
want freedom to go where you want
freedom to do nothing in life you know
you sort of just sit back and
chill out when you want to chill out
right for me trading has given me that
freedom you know last summer this past
summer
my wife and i were just talking like hey
you know what let's get out of here
right we're in illinois it's all these
lockdowns
let's go out west right we go we look at
vrbo
found a nice cabin out in south dakota
we rented it for you know almost a week
we just stayed out in south dakota
saw you know it was at devil's peak you
saw
mount rushmore saw the stuff you know
all these dinosaur dig sites for the
kids
because trading gives me that freedom
right say you know what
i want to take a break i don't have to
go write an email to my boss oh can i
request this time off other than the
boss well you know we're kind of short
staffed you know
no um and things like that right trading
gives you that freedom to do what you
want when you want
all right that you just can't get
sometimes
in a lot of other places now i got a
special bonus for
you guys it's the order flow playbook
and this is of course i did and it's got
about
11 i think 10 or 11 trade setups based
on the order flow
okay so i'm going to give you access to
that for free and i sell it
right for 297. i mean you can look on
the website go to orderflows.com
playbook.html you can see the page 297
i'll give you that for free also so you
got a lot of
ways to learn order flow plus a live
weekly
group session right you can come in and
ask your questions but you got to get
started
right you got to go to orderflows.com3
dot html
if you don't get started you're not
going to see any results
so again what you're going to get you're
going to get the order flows trader 3.0
which is the current version you can get
the order flows trading course
you can get the overflow inner circle
video series you're going to get access
to
live weekly group training and you'll
get the access to the order full
playbook
right and again you can get all of that
for just 7.49
so at the beginning i told you about my
book if you want my book on order flow
just go to orderflows.combook.html make
sure you put the dot html at the end
it takes you to this page just enter
your email
and your name click submit and takes you
to the download page
okay you go to this page by itself order
flows.com
book it's not available on that page you
have to go through that process
so again get started now go to
orderflows.com
slash off three dot
html i see that anna's already put the
link
in the chat for you guys i'll tell you
what i'm going to put the link
in there for the book just give me a
second as well
so that you can get started right and
again you know that that's you know the
main point in life is about getting
started
so you know let's go to i got a little
bit of time to go through some questions
um
what is this here uh
how is the bearish let me see here
can order flow be applied to
longer swing trading time frames and
again you know
you're dealing with order flow right
it's based on what's happening right now
in the markets
and if you're you could use it for trade
entry
right but you still at the same time you
got to be managing the trade
and the best way to manage the trade is
based on what's happening in the order
flow
right so if things turn if you're long
and things turn bearish in the order
flow
well chances are the trade's not going
to be very effective much longer
yes there will be a replay for this and
you know another question i get
often is you know does it work with
forex does it work with
stocks you know i'm a futures guy i've
been in you know
in chicago right it's all the futures
exchanges
it's
it's um yeah you can use it with stocks
but again you have to be trading stocks
that
are liquid right that trade decent
volume
so because again you're dealing with
volume so you want to have decent volume
pacman says what's the link for the book
it's in the chat but just go to
orderflows.com here i'll put the link
back up here
here order flows.combook.html
there he asked we'd like to review this
in traders world
magazine yeah yeah send me an email
larry about that now
you know a question i get is you know
i've got a lot of tools because
there's sort of a question in here about
linking it with strategy builder
in ninjatrader you know a lot of these
tools
they're not by themselves right i have
other
indicators based on order flow right
that allow that
really is everything step step step step
step
required in it now sort of these tools
are these these pre-programmed tools in
the it's in there uh harry the tools
that you see
in the software
right they're there to highlight
specific actions in the order flow
right because as a trader right you want
to
know when something is bullish or
bearish then you still got to put the
pieces
in the sale people say well it's not
really automated well it's not it's not
meant to be
automated right it's to help you
understand what's happening in the order
flow
so that's you know i i
don't really like to automate things to
the sense that you know i just turn on
the computer and walk away
you know as a trader you have to trade
right but
this is to help you understand what's
happening in the order flow as opposed
to just giving you the volume numbers
right he's saying hey you know what this
volume is bearish
or this volume is bullish or hey you
know what
you have this series of imbalances it's
bullish
right because you know it's easy to miss
things
in in the market right especially when a
market's moving fast especially if
you're trading
you know nasdaq or mnq you know even es
at times it moves very fast right you
want to have things that's going to help
you
process the information now
harry it's not in the chat the emails
are there the book is not you have to go
to this page
orderflows.combook.html
then you have to enter your name and
your email address
so anyway i'll end it there again yo
larry send me an email
um about traders world and
again you guys got any questions you
know you can send me an email my email
is real simple it's just mike
order flows.com so
i'll end it there thanks anna for having
me and you know what everybody
enjoy the rest of your day wherever you
are i'm in chicago and it
seems like winter is coming back even
though it's first day of spring is in a
few days
so have a great week everybody and
thanks for attending
bye